en mi intento por tener un portafolio
cuyo rendimiento depende solamente de mi
habilidad para identificar buenas y
malas compañías y no está sujeto a lo
que dicta el mercado he comprado una
acción de la empresa ve que es una
compañía muy buena ya que se desempeñó
mejor de lo esperado y corte dos
acciones de la compañía
porque cuestan cinco dólares cada una y
quería cortar la misma cantidad de
dinero ahora lo que quiero hacer es
suponiendo que mi predicción fue
correcta de que la compañía de le irá
mejor que a la compañía a cómo le irá a
mi inversión si el mercado de valores
sube y si el mercado de valores baja
primero imaginemos la situación en la
que el mercado de valores sube por lo
que las acciones de ambas compañías
subirán aunque el porcentaje de la
compañía de subida más de lo que sube la
compañía el costo de las acciones debe
llegar a 15 dólares aumentó un 50 por
ciento
y digamos que la compañía
sólo subió un 20% por lo que sus
acciones valen 6 dólares que sucede en
esta situación claramente ganaré
bastante de mi acción de la compañía de
en mi posición larga así que cuando sube
el mercado de 10 tendré 15 dólares gane
5 dólares y claramente perdí a mi
posición corta ya que la vendí a 5 y
ahora tendré que comprar la de nuevo a 6
en caso de que quiera cubrir esta
posición corta de manera que los 10
dólares de esta posición
recordemos que tenía 2 acciones pues
ahora tendré 12 dólares y como esta es
mi posición corta voy a perder 2 dólares
pero ya que la compañía que yo pensé que
le iría mejor le fue mejor en un 50% aún
logré ganar algo gane 3 dólares ahora
veamos qué pasa si todo el mercado de
valores baja y voy a suponer que soy
buena al elegir la compañía correcta y
que se mantiene mi tesis de que la
compañía ve le va a ir mejor que la
compañía
en este escenario negativo
cae un 20% por lo que cada acción acaba
costando 8 dólares así que creemos que
esto es el mercado a la alza y aquí va a
estar el mercado a la baja y ahora mi
posición en be pasa de 10 dólares a 8
dólares por lo que pierdo 2 dólares en
mi posición larga pero al bajar el
mercado tuve razón al pensar que la
compañía no le iría tan bien como al ave
pues bajó un 50 por ciento
de manera que sus acciones que eran en
así que mi posición corta a quedan de 10
a 5
y como esa es una posición corta vendí
la acción a 10 y la puedo volver a
comprar a 5 obtuve 5 dólares de ganancia
cuando bajó del mercado así que a pesar
de que baje el mercado y pierdo en mi
posición larga gane y compense la
pérdida con mi posición corta así que a
pesar de la baja del mercado contando
con el supuesto de que mi predicción de
ambas compañías fue correcto aún tengo 3
dólares de ganancia lo que establecimos
aquí fue una cobertura larga y corta lo
genial de esta es que depende solamente
de la habilidad del inversionista para
diferenciar a las compañías que son más
probable que le vaya bien con respecto a
otras compañías y no depende tanto de la
habilidad de adivinar cómo se comportará
el mercado cuando las personas hablan de
fondos de cobertura larga y corta hablan
de coberturas como las que acabamos de
ver para evitar algo del riesgo del
mercado